our ongoing series a more perfect union
aims to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us this morning we meet two
strangers who had life-changing
surgeries in New York City yesterday
it's a story of two fathers one
suffering from kidney complications
since childhood and the other giving the
gift of life Don Dahler shows us how a
t-shirt brought them together
Don good morning good morning we met
both Richie and Rob here in New York
less than 24 hours before Thursday
surgery the two men now share an
unbreakable bond with help from a
t-shirt and a viral social media post
what was the moment when you realized
that I need to have a transplant well
you know what there are five moments and
those are my five kids that's what was
my inspiration in terms of I got to do
something you know I'm desperate
suffering from chronic kidney disease
and facing his own mortality 60-year old
Robert Leibowitz knew a little
desperation could go a long way this
little baby right here is all covered
with pixie dust over the summer while on
a family vacation at Disney World
Rob a single father of five wore this
t-shirt for nine consecutive days with a
plea his blood type and a prayer thought
you know if I can get one person who's
my blood type to just respond and maybe
that's my match you know it's worth the
$35 investment for the shirt this
amazing couple Rocio and Juan sandable
took a picture of it and said you mind
if I post it within the first week
90,000 Facebook shares three days
walking around the parks my phone
wouldn't stop ringing I have an extra
kidney it's not like I need them both on
the other end of one of those calls a
complete stranger 39 year old father of
two from Indiana Ritchie Sully my
biggest worry is my daughter's losing me
or me not getting to spend time with
them so you know it was kind of a
no-brainer and what is that process a
few trips to New York a lot of blood
work and every month or so we do another
round of labs because as you can imagine
it's an emotional roller coaster and you
know I can't say enough about this guy
after a mountain of tests and months
filled with anxiety Rob received word
Richie's kidney was a match tell we've
got that moment that she got the phone
call and broke down I screamed but of
course screaming in New York nobody
everybody ignores you anyway words
cannot explain you know this guy saved
my life he's saving my life he's giving
me more time with my kids
he doesn't have only two good kidneys he
has a big heart I'm bigger than you can
ever imagine the doctor brought up what
will you do after the surgery if if Rob
never calls you again I don't know how
to answer that I never once considered
it we talk on the phone not every day
but maybe a cheap date that would make
you a horrible person but I hadn't
considered it because I want I didn't
think he would do that and - it's not my
kidney anymore the reason all the media
is picking this up is not because of me
not because I'm getting a kidney but
it's because of this guy who's doing
such an amazing thing you know there's
so many for a complete stranger exactly
the cure for chronic kidney disease is
here and it's humanity in this guise the
new name for you manly because you know
everybody can help and we can report
this morning that the surgery was a
success
both Richie and Rob are doing well both
are resting comfortably at the hospital
and both will stay in the city for the
next few weeks as doctors monitor their
progress
they are certainly bonded for life but I
marvel that a total stranger can do that
for somebody else it makes you think
about your own life would you do that
and I don't know that he wanted to be
anonymous at first but then he decided I
need to let people know to not be afraid
yeah and also that this can give hope to
so many other people and by the way if
you donate a kidney you immediately go
to the top of the recipient list in case
you get sick eventually and need another
kidney that's good well I like what he
said the cure is humanity yeah that's
great great guys
so he said beautiful story of grace the
next time